buongiorno ragazzi si allora anche oggi
approfitteremo dei vantaggi della
tecnologia per continuare a studiare
intanto abbia mandato 230 pagine gli
esercizi da fare per i baci baci
ciao studenti online iscriviti subito al
canale per non perdere neanche un video
va bene ragazzi allora state attenti che
faccio un appello giulia monti coli the
block roberto vianello presente prof
allora qualcuno dica monti coli che dire
presente poi andarsene non equivale a
essere presente durante la lezione marco
rovelli presente prof
debora garay adam e stano presente
prossimo la pronunciato male come si
pronuncia
debora va va bene debora giovanni di
marzia presente prof
ma a petto nudo mama's ma stiamo
scherzando ma mettiti una maglietta prof
casa mia faccio quello che mi pare ok di
marzio lascia lasciamo perdere che è
meglio
lavinia rubelli assente un'altra volta
immaginavo no profit ci sono e ci sono
presenti ma rubelli ma stiamo scherzando
ma cosa stai facendo
ma guardi che siamo congiunti a bella
non credo proprio quello mainardi lo
riconosco da tatuaggi quelle l'uomo via
penate prendete rovino a stronzo
allora ragazzi smettiamola che questa è
una lezione e non è una puntata di
temptation iceland di marcia ma ma stai
buttando delle palline di carta sulla
videocamera si prof al trentino mi sento
in classe allora faccio un faccio finta
di non averne visto e ne sentito senti a
proposito di marzio
già che ci siamo ricordo mi sa che punto
dei promessi sposi eravamo arrivati
praticamente siamo arrivati a quando
si sa va da frà cristoforo e disfa auto
blu corro con il mio fra propri per la
grande ragazzi ma stiamo scherzando
scherzi a parte
ma che cos'è questa cosa basta belli
continua tu dove eravamo rimasti
i prof allora cioè lucia punto chi evade
ha previsto
chi è chi può a sua volta va da don
rodriguez rodrigo rubelli rodrigo e tv
di don don rodrigo rubelli mi vuoi
veramente far credere che si sia
bloccato la videocamera guarda guarda
che lo vedo il tuo amico dietro che si
muove no no non ho parole ragazza allora
per oggi va bene così perché non ne
posso più
e se il video arriva a 50 mila light
forse forse farò un'altra lezione
va bene
[Musica]